[Music]
you might be then what this guy's still
alive
whippin slept for 70 years sir you
should yell celebrating seeing the world
I went under the world was at war I wake
up they say we won we've made some
mistakes along the way some very
recently you here with a mission sir I
am trying to get me back in the world
trying to save it hide your secret
weapon Howard Stark fished that out of
the ocean when he was looking for you
he thought what we think the tesseract
could be the key to unlimited
sustainable energy that's something the
world sorely needs who took it from you
he's called Loki he's not from around
here
there's a lot we'll have to bring you up
to speed on if you're in the world has
gotten even stranger then you already
know at this point I doubt I think would
surprise me ten bucks says you're wrong
does a debriefing packet waiting for you
back at your apartment is there anything
you can tell us about the tesseract that
we ought to know now you should have
left it in the ocean
you